we talked earlier in the show about this
question what is the role of Russia and
Vladimir Putin Russia certainly helped
Donald Trump be elected president of the
United States and now the day after the
election of Donald Trump Vladimir Putin
says oh wow we're ready to restore full
ties with the United States now
understand what this means translated
this means Putin said Putin is ready for
Russia to have sanctions against it
lifted remember no you're the puppet no
you're the puppet Vladimir Putin is
going to run circles around this 70 year
old who has no experience in anything
related to what he's going to be thrown
into in January of 2017 uh we are now
going to be talking about Vladimir Putin
and how he is looking to manipulate
Donald Trump hoping that Donald Trump
will recognize the annexation of Crimea
and drop sanctions I really don't get
this because it exposes Trump to then
say uh to then be accused of being soft
on Russia and we know that that's not
something that Donald Trump wants to be
accused of but can you imagine hours
hours after Donald Trump becomes the
president vladimir putin all of a sudden
says hey we're ready to get back
together with you guys and really what
he wants is the sanctions lifted isn't
it I think that were so far detached now
from the Cold War that a lot of people
don't understand the atrocities going on
in Russia yeah but poo in jails is a
political opponents and maiya members of
the media so it's not really surprising
that he would extend a hand out to a
fellow authoritarian in Donald Trump and
this is totally up politically
opportunistic Rachel I mean this is just
Putin season-opening and he wants it one
prediction i have made from the very
start and i'm sure you can find this and
some other clip is me saying that Putin
will do whatever it takes yeah to get
Trump to be his puppet to destabilize
the west and he did it I I don't know
exactly how but he did it this is sort
of twofold number one as i mentioned
bladimir Putin wants the sanctions gone
and he will do what he can to to get
Trump to help make that happen also
Putin wants Russia to really be seen as
part of Europe in it at least
ideologically and culturally so Putin
can use Trump to restore
ties with the US if he can convince him
to do that and if nobody sort of talk
sense into him then Trump brings him
brings Putin back into the whole
European milieu Putin's ego grows even
more and next thing you know Vladimir
Putin is considered a sort of legitimate
leader that we shouldn't be scared but
also what vulnerabilities is this going
to expose us to in cyberspace I've been
worrying about that a lot I me did the
but don't worry Baron Trump is so good
with computers cyborg he is going to
just take care of internet security some
on stage there with Donald Trump he's
gonna kill it is the new director of NSA
I can't help but feel that Putin is just
going to make Donald Trump look really
really weak weak and Putin lives and
breathes this Donald Trump at 70 is
getting intelligence briefings for the
first time Vladimir Putin has been
involved in insecurity and in politics
for so long former KGB agent etcetera
Russia is going to play Trump like a
violin and we are going to be here to
see it happen